[Music]
all right this is a short video just to
raise some questions as you provide your
video okay so again my students don't
really know this a attack because we
don't use it because it's not really an
energetic ritual it's one of those weird
dto you leftovers in my opinion okay so
I have to teach it to Virginia uh and
we'll just do this more conceptually
academically to get
you to start to think about the
technique okay and then later I'll do
one like how would I do it okay so uh
the attack
is grab grab the grab the shoulder and
strike okay so that that's the
attack um all right so there's a couple
things every time you see this technique
and it's you know or most times let's
say I'm sure someone does it a little
different okay but definitely more
commonly and in the videos uh that you
sent me they all did this is the naga's
front foot does not
move and so they will I'm going to teach
Virginia
uh they'll t
con out of the way of the strike don't
move your front foot you see this kind
of stuff
okay and uh as as I do it it it looks I
I don't want to give I didn't give her
the handw we just keeping it simple just
looking at the angle deviation okay so
as you see it it looks like it's going
to work every time okay the UK comes in
and she 10 come she's out of the way
looks like it it's going to work
okay
um but if you pay
attention if I hold
here and I'm
here I can't hit the target because my
fingers aren't the
weapon I can't hit the target they hit
the target I have to be
closer here
I can drive through her
okay from this grab
distance I can't it's just my fingers
are doing
it
okay so point
one this with this arm here doing kadori
as a normal kadori shui is not available
that's point one
point
two as she's doing a
Tenon then I must be
entering because we turn when pushed and
we enter when pulled okay so you reverse
engineer the technique so as the nogget
does the tencon I must have been coming
in okay
and then if you look at that
then that would be spinal
displacement so if I were to spinally
displace then you now have the bigger
problem the problem of the first point
gets even worse because I'm push her
ahead of the strike it gets further out
due to the inertial change okay okay so
again you can reverse engineer if the
Naga is
tenoning then you knew that UK was
assigned spinal
displacement that's point two point
three if you now review 01 under spinal
displacement this problem gets worse I
miss even more
okay um
if you now reverse engineer from the
strike so I'm
here so I
grab and not
there
here now it's starts to make
sense it also makes sense why you would
hold someone's arm you see this a lot
boom boom you pulled people into Stripes
okay so this is probably makes more
sense this way I'm not saying it does
that way but it makes more
sense now if you do
that when she tries to ten con now this
this doesn't
work
okay so consider that as well as you're
trying to do your stuff
okay and I don't want to just leave it
up to you so it's not fair meaning I'll
give what I'm thinking
probably is as she's
grabbing and she's pulling me into the
strike you you now can follow the r rule
if she's pulling then I
enter so I get pulled and I strike her
and I'll tell you why that's
important okay on the other version if
it did work at
all I don't think it does so she comes
here even though she can't really hit
the
target everyone that does this ver
blocks that's a young young Clash
okay if however she's pulling me in hold
on I got to talk if she's pulling me in
and I go to strike and she goes to block
the
strike then I didn't do the Yong Yong
clash and then my counter can go from
there so just playing with it now in
light of all of this I think it makes
more sense she pulled and I came in to
hit and as I she pulled came to hit her
arm is there
okay and then everything else would come
from there what whatever the technique
is based on what she does after that
strike that's where everything else
comes from okay
so put that into your experiments cuz
that's what I wanted I want you to
experiment with the technique put that
in with your
experiments um as you're looking at more
videos and as you're trying to film it
and and help me out with trying to
understand your questions uh and see
what you come up with too and then I'll
play from that from there as well and
see what I come up with okay